here in the the region around fifty
percent of the population is under 30
years old and a biggest problem is that
the government is the biggest employer
we need to actually look at the
statistics but it says that eighty-five
percent of the jobs are created by SM is
so we need to concentrate more and
concentrate on making it easier for
entrepreneurs to package their ideas to
reach finance we need to get out of the
idea of job seekers government jobs more
secure jobs we need to make them know
that risk calculated this is a good
thing to have failure isn't a problem
people usually fail many times before
before succeeding once and that that is
all that counts we need to give them
role models we have a lot of the regions
of successful entrepreneurs that really
made it but our biggest problem is
nobody knows about them so the region is
rich and talent rich and youth we just
need to put proper channels for them to
be out there